what up I'm ashamed I'm Kelly and I'm
going undercover on the Internet
this is actually okay can you do one
first up read it I've never been on
reddit you are paying at a girl and
suddenly we show you in Kelly's house up
and starts peeing in it too
what do you do I just continue your pee
don't even acknowledge that I'm there
that also feels like I'm peeing in the
same urinals you so that also makes me
uncomfortable
weird question Twatter Twitter I'm
pretty sure I just got into an argument
with Machine Gun Kelly in traffic does
anyone know if he drives a faded black
in 1598 Honda Civic ash let's talk about
it you Galvan seriously are seriously it
was probably me in traffic but no it was
not me in the black 1998 Honda Civic
arguing in traffic does sound like
something I would do driving a black
1998 Honda Civic does not hashtag let's
talk about it did we ever find out where
Machine Gun Kelly took that policewoman
in bird box no we're still cruising
waiting for that bird box equal to pop
right back in more screentime wait is
Machine Gun Kelly on every Netflix movie
now hashtag viral yeah yeah I am yeah
posted Wikipedia regarding his political
philosophy Michelle Oakley identifies as
in Hanoi goose oh I was pretty good
that's facts
MGK found himself working at Chipotle
tax that was my job right after high
school I hated Christmas break cuz all
my friends from college would come back
and they'd be like damn like I thought
you were supposed to be a huge rapper
what happened and I just mean you want
to self talk because our tacos dude
let's let's roll people always was like
dude let me get double chicken for
single chicken price and I was like
homie we can do this all day like well
how much do you tell me when to stop
I didn't carry I look back on those days
fondly if I never have to smell hot
steaming sour cream because when I had
to wash the dishes and you have to do
the stuff and then mrs. officer by Lil
Wayne was always playing on the radio so
I'll never forget being like dude I I I
hate every time I hear that song I
smelled sour cream it's gross
Baker and his Baker I'm still new to
hearing my name is Laurie Baker and his
family moved all around the world and
took up residence abroad from Egypt to
Germany true I grew up in Egypt till I
was five or six years old
Egypt and Kenya and then uh Germany for
a bit then I came to the United States
and was apparently speaking Arabic to
everybody pora don't know how to feel
about that because I have no idea what
that is
so cor it's not like an ex-girlfriend of
mine as I'm confused our Machine Gun
Kelly concerts say for a 15 year old
girl who is mature and smart sure as
opposed to dumb as [ __ ] yes how can I be
fun and interesting like Machine Gun
Kelly
I don't like smiling so I'm gonna cover
my smile a lot mmm that's flattering I'm
awkward have Lana Del Rey and Machine
Gun Kelly ever released his song
together no but we have a song together
and get it together in the studio a lot
of really cool BTS video I have from
that session actually I wish that song
would come out I mean it's that's on me
to do that but I'll put it out IMDB
his stage name is Shangaan Kylie was
given for his rapid-fire lyrical flow I
hate people trying to describe me it's
so annoying his rapid-fire lyrical flow
shut up none of us talk like that but
true but like it goes without being said
Colson Baker aka rapper Machine Gun
Kelly will be working with Saturday
Night Live cast member Pete Davidson
again on the big screen and the latter's
untitled shut up it's house
Davison comedy Universal oh yeah I was
really intimidated because judge such a
legend but uh he just spoke to me like
God through a speaker system the whole
time I was doing the scene and was like
okay
completely off script but then I did it
and I would just say that and it would
just it would be yeah it was really
funny I just got to antagonize Pete
Davis in the whole time which is awesome
because if you have friends you know
that putting through them through pain
is very satisfying
up next YouTube Oh God
so talk how we met Pete Dave isn't close
what are you doing an album together
what's with all the interviews watch it
first off watch your tone but second off
no when I do an album together however
he's on my album Oh tell diabla
he's the count on the interlude message
from the count and I think we'll also do
a tour together as well
so next Instagram I wonder how the [ __ ]
do you smoke so much and drink so much
and got some buddies has indeed drugs
but still managed to live and slay mood
that's me this morning I was dead an
hour ago but here we are my friends
walked into my room to wake me up today
and left after they took two steps like
it was that it was that chaotic or
whatever word you'd use tips I have a
lot of water
facial regiments for sure I was under I
patched up before I even walked in here
I'm on zero food right now all caffeine
we're on like a quadruple espresso so if
I held my hand in front of the camera I
try to shake like a maraca but my skin
and life other than that is thriving so
all right that's it I'm signing off bye